well guys it's Chris Delia
no it's brusquely a day I know but mud
oh oh that's dumb the way it started huh
you get a phone call
Oh a professional is it that [ __ ]
thing no first of all this is too small
the end table is too small it's not big
it's not [ __ ] heavy enough so when
you move the microphone I take with it
cuz I don't know my own strength
but that's what they're saying about me
now right it's not strength nobody's
saying that all right you see it's in
your underwear in front of you know
millions hundreds and thousands millions
I'll say man dude ah here we are
fighter in the kid it's the number two
podcast right congratulate we did
numbers and we're actually bigger than
you guys get two since you already
listened to congratulations this week
now this one is you're like okay well
listen to this one too I guess
no well I'm on this one as well no so
hello guys and I'm with my guest no
you're not like you're not gonna run
over Helen you know I gotta take some so
everybody knows you as Chris D'Elia and
alia that's what I'm saying so for you
guys who who say that no it's Delia guy
what's that Christy Leah got like a
little Miss Julie yeah they don't say
that right they don't say that I know
most a couple of name a couple of things
I want to say we performed last night
okay and I have pointers for you so that
I was better right so no is that but
that's what they were all like you're
better than him we went and I went well
he didn't really have time cuz he got
thrown off by the crowd cuz he has he
got thrown off no I didn't you went who
went first who won first me or you I
forget I went first so that's what we
call that's what we call it I I was
happy to have been in the lineup and
could have chosen we happy they said
Chris do you wanna are cases from our
Ireland said yeah he said would you mind
if I put you up first because if Chris
has to follow you then he'll be
depressed if that was Martin he would be
sexy but it's not it's a [ __ ]
horrible
he's got a very accent is bad yeah he
looks he's you he's the Irish Chris
D'Elia he's me if like I was on the
streets for yeah for months yeah he's
you if you came up with all like from
Ireland and you had no don't do your
accents my accents are so spot-on though
it's kind let me ask you a question
seriously yeah what
little boy is freezing outside because
you stole his outfit you stole his whole
outfit look at that little boy shirt you
have on dude this is sounds a little
same oh I love all set yeah but that
shirt well it's a little boy shirt okay
listen
yeah it the stripes that go this way are
flattering they're a horizontal stripes
for those of you listening to this make
my make my shoulders but it makes Brian
ring out as brought my shoulder oh my
shoulders for the broadness that they
actually are you kind of you look like
you're you know what you did you look at
you put on the outfit and then grew up
that's what you look like that's what
you [ __ ] look like what the [ __ ] my
future oh [ __ ] dude hey put your [ __ ] I
put my son down you brought this up yeah
cuz I want to ask you I had to put it I
had to put my sunglasses on so obnoxious
cuz your future so bright yeah that's
exactly yeah okay so you get it I don't
get it cuz I want to ask you seriously I
want to get I want to get serious and I
want to I want to start reading question
alright start with a future so bright
sucks the man I need to wear sunglasses
indoors you don't I want to start with
this question right let's start with a
general man ready right I'm looking at
you here you got holes in your jeans you
guys cuz I live life I live life I know
so let's start with this number will
will dilate down you know what that
means I know it dilate hands man you
know but so I read bro you know okay but
so you read you know you read Twitter no
no no no I read no I'm gonna read and
comments but no I don't gonna read soon
your tombstone in five years cuz you do
oh good well be there what's my
tombstone gonna saying what are you
gonna say I'm if you know what it said
honestly YouTube so I was gonna say he
tried it's gonna be dot dot dot question
mark it's gonna trail off your tombstone
cut a trail off no what are you gonna
say at my funeral I asked you to speak
I'm gonna honestly go like this
I'll speak and then I'll go on there and
then it'll be like ladies and gentlemen
Chris D'Elia
and everyone you know when they're done
cheering or whatever like my funeral I
know I know I'm gonna be guys guys guys
he died guys he died I'm gonna have to
sit at a [ __ ] little [ __ ] load yeah
and I'm gonna be up there with my iced
americano sipping and so disrespectful
but I know but it's I know but funerals
are early so so uh
so I wanna be like guys he lived life
and he he changed the world in the
little ways that people do sometimes and
also no sad I'm gonna let out a big
[ __ ] rip fart I'm gonna let out a
[ __ ] huge just [ __ ] oh oh it's
gonna come out like that and I'm gonna
go like this
oh [ __ ] I'm sorry and then I'm gonna
take my sunglasses off and I'm gonna go
with my mouth and I'm gonna [ __ ] have
two big middle fingers I'm not gonna do
it like they do like that I like it I'm
gonna [ __ ] it and the whole things and
I'm gonna go like this my new special
comes out whenever and whatever time
you're using the night of mood walls out
launching pad and you're gonna
disrespect me by oh yeah one thing what
sunglasses off in the middle of it
though that's so bad can I ask you so ok
on that note next real question so
you're almost you're gonna be 40 I'm not
even close to 40 no you're you're gonna
be 40 in already nine months right 39
and it's got about nine months right so
so so really in like 14 months or
something or 15 whatever it is you're
gonna be 40 now so your auto year is 12
months be your audience and you're
getting great so your audience that's
young is going to Maui's know it's going
to shrink my audience goes from [ __ ]
they did the [ __ ] demographic thing I
went to the demographic yeah pleasure
they're 18 there's or audience is
literally two nine ninety-two 72 they go
like this and I and I go like what
that's how big are these but what's that
demo and they go like this they're
looking at these spreadsheets and
they're all [ __ ] it's like it's like
go like this so they're like well I'm
looking here but it's just it's everyone
they go no they go it's everyone and I
go it's off for [ __ ] sake and I took
my sunglasses off and I [ __ ] walk out
of there dude well who was it that said
you've seen guys in lab coats and [ __ ]
and like yeah [ __ ] so it was a lab I
guess yeah scientists yeah look at all
the numbers 100% never like we don't
they go like this you know these reports
we've never seen something like this you
know cuz they're [ __ ] dorks you know
so they're like
movor [ __ ] paid you after pagelets
the hell is yeah like I've never seen
anything like this usually demos they're
like 15 years or so and they go the
earth is just and one guy goes like this
and he's shaking and he's [ __ ]
shaking and he says mr. mr. D'Elia your
demo it's and I said what say it and he
said it's just it's 9:00 to 72 and then
did you go any guest any [ __ ] white
you go alright I go like this well I
guess that's how it's gonna be and I
[ __ ] kept my sunglasses on and I
strut it out of there and on the way out
as the door closed I [ __ ] [ __ ] my
pants and I didn't give a [ __ ] it's at
my car all the way home and you heard
this somebody got a bucket yep and I
drove all the way home with the [ __ ] in
my pants because I don't give a [ __ ]
dude you just sat in your shop yep okay
let me ask you this so I appreciate all
that no problem so we know that now
you're gonna be 40 which means you're
gonna be an adult almost because you're
not an adult you're a tall boy you're
you say I'm right I'm not let's start
with a general question so I can help
you what do what do you think you're
[ __ ] doing bro no I wanted to start
with that general question like stop
doing that because it's my statures in
front of me right ate your sunglasses we
can both agree that the future is not
behind us right can we agree we agree
that the futures not behind we can agree
with that okay okay now our eyes are
we're in front of us or behind us what
our eyes are where our eyes are we're on
our face in front of us and the face is
in the front right yes so if our future
now we agreed is in front of us Yeah
right okay and our faces
face forward right okay you've now my
dance teacher now my future what is it
dude it's too bright so I have to put
these [ __ ] shades on otherwise
otherwise otherwise otherwise
otherwise oh my god I say otherwise
ahead Iraq's now you're familiar with
cataracts because you for sure had
cataract surgery did not you're 52 no no
and it's all good no but that's how it
is
don't sit your coffee like that my guest
on my podcast dude it's so respectful
how I'm being to be brutally honest with
you no it's not yes it is so so listen
bro you can't just say general [ __ ] like
my futures too bright
how is it to breath where do you where
do you think where the [ __ ] do you think
there is for you to go and know my
tombstones gonna send that teenage look
you know what my two sons gonna say what
you [ __ ] skater from the 90s he's
gonna say he just keeps kicking man and
even still it's not gonna say he kept
kicking he's gonna say he just play your
dusty I'm not dusty dude to be honest be
my age going ah dude what's up with
coffee
you know whenever you but I don't do
that i talk about raccoons you know what
do you do Brian what did you talk about
on stage as artistic last night I was
metaphor really yeah what did you talk
about my act was a bit bird heavy out it
was a bit bird heavy you talked a lot
about birds cuz I'm a bird satirist um
you're not a bird Saturday I'm an avian
humorist at least give me that okay